– Steckt ihr in einer Beziehungskrise?
– Eine was?
– Was Nina meint, ist:
Habt ihr euch gestritten?
– Nein.
– Selma antwortet nicht.
Na und?
Vielleicht hat sie einfach keine Zeit,
mit dir zu schreiben.
Und sie arbeitet doch jetzt auch, oder?
– Aber sie geht seit gestern
nicht ans Telefon,
obwohl ich dreimal angerufen habe.
– Ja, das kann tausend Gründe haben.
Wahrscheinlich hat sie einfach keine Zeit.
– Ich denke ja:
Sie will dich testen.
Sie will nicht, dass du aufgibst!
– So ein Unsinn!
– Das ist überhaupt gar kein Unsinn.
– Selma hat deinen Anruf bestimmt gesehen.
Jetzt warte mal ab,
sonst nervst du sie nur.
– Obwohl sie deinen Anruf gesehen hat,
geht sie nicht ran.
Komisch.
Ich denke,
sie ist doch sauer.
Vielleicht hast du
irgendwas Falsches gesagt.
– Nein, wir haben nur über
ihr Praktikum geredet.
– Die Frage ist nicht,
worüber ihr gesprochen habt,
sondern was du gesagt hast.
Zwischen Männern und Frauen,
da gibt’s manchmal …
Kommunikationsprobleme.
Mhm.
Ja, vielleicht ist Selma sauer,
obwohl für dich alles okay ist.
Oder ihr ist irgendwas passiert.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
– Sebastian!
– Was denn?
– Mann!
Du sollst ihn nicht verunsichern,
sondern ihm helfen.
– Ich helf ihm doch!
– Hm. Ich muss das klären.
– Also, Basti,
du hast wirklich gar keine Ahnung.
Von nichts!
– Von nichts.